[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 135 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm good.
How are you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: I'm not sure
what's happening today.
I feel like I have a very
deep voice today. (DEEP VOICE)
I'm doing well.
MELANIE WARRICK:
(DEEP VOICE) You do.
You have a very deep voice.
I'm your father. (NORMAL
VOICE) OK, so, Mark--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Tell
me about this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, this week,
we're going to chat with Emi
Martínez, who is the technical
lead for a company called
VirusTotal.
VirusTotal is a
company that does
a lot of really interesting
stuff in the security space.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
we like security.
Well, as always, before
we get into the interview,
we will start off with our
Cool Things of the Week.
And we will end with the
Question of the Week.
And this week's question we
have a special guest who's
going to help answer
a question that we
got from one of our listeners--
the question being that
what is the best practice
for multitenancy in
Google Cloud Spanner,
especially if customers
are not of the same size
and have unequal load.
And that's coming
from Andrew Sheridan.
Yeah, we'll have Robert
Kubis a little bit later.
All right, Cool Things
of the Week-- so one
of the cool things is that,
basically, this last month,
they've added a new data
type, new data import formats,
and finer cost controls.
And so the new data
type is numeric,
and the data formats for
ingest are Parquet and ORC.
So that's basically available
as a natively supported format
for ingest into BigQuery.
And then, like I said, there'll
be some more finer cost
controls, and that's
all in the blog post
that we will include
in the show notes.
Another cool thing of the
week is that Dataflow Stream
Processing now supports
Python, which is a great thing
to be supporting,
because, frankly, Python
has such an important
language in the data space.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
MELANIE WARRICK: So now you
can use that with Dataflow--
Dataflow Stream, I should say.
MARK MANDEL: My Python
is terrible-- like, just
really bad.
MELANIE WARRICK: But,
yeah, that's fine,
because Python loves everyone.
Python will be very
easy for you if you ever
want to approach it.
MARK MANDEL: I've tried
a couple of times.
NARRATOR: Mark realizes
that his approach has
enraged the Python, and to
be safe, he must retreat.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, you did?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I did
some Ansible stuff in Python.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
were you doing wrong?
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
MELANIE WARRICK: Anyways.
MARK MANDEL: One other
cool thing of the week
is that we're announcing a new
certification for Google Cloud
Certified-- the
Associate Cloud Engineer.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, and this is
in combination with some
of the other certifications
that we have out there,
like Professional Cloud
Architect, which came out in
2016, and also Data Engineer.
So this is just another way
to further expand and become
an expert in the space.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
if you're interested,
an Associate Cloud
Engineer is someone
that deploys applications,
monitors operations,
and manages
enterprise solutions.
MELANIE WARRICK: There you go.
MARK MANDEL: So if
that's something
that you think
that you fit into,
this certification
may well be for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Last
cool thing of the week
that we wanted to mention
is relation to Next,
which many of you have
heard us talk about before,
is coming up later this month.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, my God.
I'd better get some stuff done.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, you've
got a lot of work to do.
MARK MANDEL: I'd
better do some stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
think we both do.
So there is a blog
post that's out that
emphasizes some of the AI
machine learning, talks
that are going to be going on
that people should check out--
some of them being like the
"How to Get Started Injecting
AI Into Your Applications,"
"Architecting Live NCAA
Predictions From
Archives to Insights."
This was something we
mentioned in Cool Things
a couple of months back.
Eric Schmidt, one
of our colleagues,
was working on this.
We also have another
colleague, Martin Gorner,
who has been doing this whole
series around "TensorFlow Deep
Learning and Modern
Convolutional Neural Nets
Without a PhD."
So all of these things
will be at NEXT.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
actually worth noting,
if you haven't been back to
the NEXT website for a while,
there's actual times
for all the sessions,
so you can actually go in and
see what everything is doing,
all the tracks, and
everything that's going on.
So there is a lot of content.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
definitely go check it out
if you're registered.
If you have your
tickets, go in, sign up,
make sure you have
a bit of an idea.
I think it's going to
take some planning.
There is really
a lot of content.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That sounds fun.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we go
chat with our friend,
Emi, over at VirusTotal and talk
about all the security things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that.
So we have a really
interesting project today.
Emi Martínez is here--
a VirusTotal tech lead--
to talk to us about
VirusTotal today.
Emi, how are you doing today?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: I'm doing great.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so
much for coming to join us.
VirusTotal is super interesting.
But before we sort of
start talking about that,
do you want to tell us
a little bit about you
and what you do here at Google?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: OK, so
I'm actually tech lead
for VirusTotal.
And that's no more than I
am a software engineer that
gets to work with
legal, with marketing,
with sales, et cetera.
I happened to actually bootstrap
the sales at VT at the time,
because after acquisition,
we didn't have any sales
personnel, and before that,
we didn't have either.
So basically, I was
wearing the engineering
hat in the mornings, and in the
afternoons, I was doing sales.
So what it means is that
I have a broad visibility
of the product, and I can
answer many questions.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, OK, so at a high
level, what is VirusTotal?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: Yeah, so most
people think that VirusTotal is
simply a publicly facing website
to which you can upload a file
and get the [INAUDIBLE] for more
than 70 anti-virus solutions
in order to get a second
opinion about the maliciousness
of a file.
And that's the
basic understanding
for the novel users.
If you are a bit more
curious, you probably
have discovered that we not
only scan files but also URLs,
domains, IP addresses.
And the bottom line is
that we're receiving
about two million files a day.
And we're doing tons of URL
scanning and domains and IPs.
So eventually, what
happens is we're not only
running AVs on files.
We are also running
all sorts of tools
that extract metadata and
relationships about files
and the other
items that we scan.
So for instance, when
you upload a file,
and it happens to
be an executable,
we will run it in a
virtualized environment.
And we'll get to see
what that file does
when it infects a machine.
We will then run all
sorts of micro services
that, for instance, if you
upload an executable file
to VirusTotal or try to
send file to VirusTotal
any compressed
bundle, it will try
to decompress it,
and, if there's
any interesting files within
that bundle, re-upload
to VirusTotal and get
the inner files scanned.
So we do tons of microservices
on the files, URLs,
and the rest of
items that we scan.
And eventually, what
happens with all this data
is it gets into our data
set, which these days is
over two billion files, and the
end product of all this work
is we get to create a service,
which I usually describe as--
Google and Facebook,
you mix them together,
and you apply them
to the malware field.
So why Google?
Because we created this thing
called VirusTotal Intelligence,
which is like a search
engine over malware.
And you get to use over
40 modifiers in order
to identify particular
malware that interests you.
So for instance, you can
do stuff like, "Hey, let me
know all of the malware
that reaches out
to Google Drive upon execution,"
or all the malware that
is detected by a given
anti-virus engine with a given
label and happens to be a
PDF that contains JavaScript.
So you can combine
more than 40 modifiers
in order to identify particular
families of malware that
interest you.
So that's the Google
side of things.
Why do you say that it's
similar to Facebook?
It's similar to
Facebook in that,
for each match of
your search results,
you get to see a profile of
every sample in the data set.
So you get to understand
the individual items
of that malware
and the individual
like through Sandboxing and
virtual environment execution
that we do.
But you also get to see the
relationships with other items
in the data set.
So has this file been
downloaded from a given URL?
Or is this file reaching
out to a given domain?
And what other files
are reaching out
to those resources?
So it builds in this
relationship notion
that is similar to
the way that Facebook
works but applied to malware.
So we built this intelligence
tool over malware
that many security companies,
security teams worldwise use,
and it has its counterpart as
an API with same functionality
but exposed
programmatically so that you
can integrate with your
programs with the core data set
that VirusTotal builds.
And that's like a very broad
overview of what we do.
MARK MANDEL: Is this something
we're doing in isolation?
Or are we doing this in
conjunction with other security
researchers or
anything like that?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: Yeah, so the
thing is, the technology itself,
we build it here in VirusTotal,
but it's used by tons
of researchers worldwide.
So the first people that use
it is the anti-virus vendors
participating in VirusTotal,
which are over 70
of them, including companies
like SimonTech, Kaspersky,
McAfee, et cetera.
And the second set of users
that we'll be using this
is security teams and
big and medium companies.
So at the end of the
day, they use the tool
and generate knowledge
about malware
that then contributes
the world-wide defenses
against the bad guys.
So in some way, we
are an ecosystem,
where all the security-related
individuals co-exist and work
with each other, sharing the
knowledge through VirusTotal.
MELANIE WARRICK: How did
the VirusTotal idea get off
the ground to begin with?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: So it's a
very interesting story.
The founder, Bernardo,
way back early 2000,
he was doing anti-virus
comparatives--
so performance comparatives of
anti-viruses for a magazine.
And he had two needs.
One-- he needed to compare
the anti-virus solutions,
and doing it manually
was difficult.
So he wanted a way to
automate that task.
And secondly, he
needed samples--
malware samples-- in order
to test this product.
So he hired a team
that went on to build
the very first VirusTotal.
And since he had this need
and he had already build this,
he said, "Hey, why not
expose it publicly?
Because I'm going to
receive malware samples.
I'm going to give value
to other users that
might have a similar use case."
So these days, we don't promote
at all anti-virus comparatives
with VT.
It's not something
you should be doing.
But that's how it was born.
And thereafter, it's
grown into a tool
that mostly any security
researcher in the world
is using in order to have a
second opinion about files.
And since we are receiving like
two million files per day--
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
EMI MARTÍNEZ: --we get to have
a massive data set with all
the behaviors, with all the
related items, and hence,
these days, it's more of a
malware research tool rather
than its initial use case.
MARK MANDEL: When
people submit stuff,
is this an entirely
automated process?
Do we have security researchers
on our side also doing stuff?
Is it combined?
What's that backhand
process look like?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: OK, so what
happens is either they use
the API or the public
web interface, which,
under the hood, uses the API.
So you submit a file.
This reaches certain Google
Cloud infrastructure, which
happens to be in App Engine.
App Engine is serving both
the public-facing front end.
And it's also acting as a
back end for the data store.
When the file
reaches App Engine,
we copy it to Google
Storage and create a task
to say, "Hey, analyze this."
And this task goes into pubsub
systems and microservices
that we run our end.
For instance, one
of them is simply
all of the AVs running
in Google Compute Engine.
So we'll subscribe to this
pubsub topic, get the file,
scan it with all
the anti-viruses,
send back the results
either via pubsub
or an HTTP post
in an internal API
to a pending store
in the data store.
Thereafter, once we have all
this knowledge in the data set,
that's when other
researchers come over,
because either they are checking
hashes and files against VT,
and they happen
comment on those files
and investigate through
the web interface
or because they have some kind
of automation pulling our feeds
of malware, et cetera.
So that's the way it works.
And the end output
of this is that, what
they research with VT, they end
up creating rules to detect it.
And so this, in some sense,
nurtures the entire security
industry.
And we're making a dent
on billions of users
through these
security products that
happen to do their research
with VT, all the AVs seen in VT,
security teams and
big companies that
try to secure their
users, et cetera.
MARK MANDEL: That's super cool.
I'm curious to know--
I mean, just on the
GCP side of things--
why did you choose App Engine?
Has that been a really
great fit for you?
How's that working?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: So if I
rewind back in time,
before the Google acquisition,
we actually ran our own data
center in our office.
And it was super noisy, and
you didn't want to be there.
And what happened is we
had a couple of MySQLs,
and we had a couple of
front end [INAUDIBLE]..
And we ended up spending more
time managing the systems
and doing administration
rather than coding.
It was horrible.
Every single day, we would have
some kind of MySQL corruption
that would lead to downtime.
So once upon a time,
before the acquisition,
Google came over and
actually offered us a deal
to go on to App Engine
for free in exchange
for malware intelligence.
And that's how our initial
relationship got forged.
And we started
building App Engine.
And I wouldn't ever return
to the initial days.
Right now, we can focus
exclusively on coding
rather than on managing systems.
And for us, it's very simliar,
because it automatically
scales.
We don't have to
worry about scale.
And it's the best
decision we ever made.
And probably, we wouldn't have
been able to grow to the size
that we are today-- two billion
files in the collection--
without the Google
infrastructure.
This accounts for two
petabytes worth of data
in Google Storage.
And that's only the files
they've [INAUDIBLE] themselves.
Then you have to
count all the metadata
that we generate for them.
MELANIE WARRICK: Is any of
that data available for people
to do research on outside
who are doing research
into security issues?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: Yeah, absolutely.
We have several offerings.
The ones that I
mentioned before,
VirusTotal
Intelligence, our API,
they are licensed
by third parties.
It's not only internal research
in VirusTotal and Google,
but rather, if you think about
the biggest companies on earth,
they probably are all
VirusTotal customers.
So are all the anti-virus
vendor and security companies
worldwide.
So they basically research
advanced, persistent threats,
which are like
state-sponsored attacks
against their companies.
Or they try to address
mass malware, which
is targeting their users
and stuff like that.
And this ends up,
as I said before,
in rules to detect malware.
And we get to impact
billions of users that way
rather than directly having
billions of users as our users.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
You mentioned also
something else interesting.
In the process of things
getting processed,
you actually grab the
file on Compute Engine,
download it, and then
apply the virus checkers
and various other
automated systems.
Do you like isolate this file?
I mean, obviously, this
might be a file that
may contain malware.
So how do you make
sure that that
doesn't spread to potentially
other parts of the system?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: When we run
the AVs against the files,
we don't really execute them.
It's like a static analysis
for the AV [INAUDIBLE]..
So in that sense, there
could be room for infection
if the AV was exploited.
But it's not like we are
actively infecting the machine.
But if we were
exploited, the nice thing
is that, since we ran
this in Compute Engine,
we have a snapshot to
which we can revert,
which would be clean.
So that allows us to
go back really quickly.
The second thing that
we do that I mentioned
is that we execute malware
in virtual environments.
So this we do, for instance,
in stuff like VirtualBox, which
is our virtualization layer.
And thanks to the
fact that recently
Google Cloud introduced
nested virtualization,
we're able to run
stuff like VirtualBox
inside Compute Engine also.
So that's the way
that it's isolated.
MARK MANDEL: I didn't actually
know you could do that,
and now I need to do that.
I need to run VirtualBox on GCE.
That's actually really cool.
EMI MARTÍNEZ: We have also
a hybrid infrastructure,
because it's not something
that you could do before.
But recently, they did this
nested virtualization stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
What are some of the more
interesting experiences
you've had with viruses
or more interesting
viruses you've seen that
you have done things that
were a little out of the norm?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: I would say
probably the most interesting
thing I can speak of that was
discovered or tracked down
and completely understood
with VirusTotal is Stuxnet.
So if you recall, Stuxnet
has been attributed,
though not confirmed-- to
be some kind of malware
that the Israeli and US
government did in order
to slow down the Nuclear
Enrichment Program of Iran.
So basically, it was malware
targeting the nuclear stations
in Iran in order to slow down
the centrifuge of uranium,
in order to enrich uranium.
So the cool thing about
this is that it was actually
discovered in 2010, and
the actual sample was in VT
since 2007.
So for three years,
it was in VT,
and no one really knew about it.
So when it was
discovered, and I think
it was people from
SimonTech, they
were able to build the
entire picture just
pulling information
from VT, the initial
dates when it was seen,
any other samples that
were related to that
initial attack, and so on.
So that's probably one of
the most interesting ones.
But there's tons, like
last year or the year
before that, we had WannaCry
that was all over the press.
And the researcher
that discovered
the kill switch in order to stop
the propagation of that worm
was using VT for that.
So it's happening all the time.
Another interesting use case
for VT is banking Trojans.
So you have this
strain of Trojans
that try to target users
of electronic banking
in order to steal credentials
and do automated transactions
of money, like wire
transfers, to the account
of either our money mule
or the end attacker.
And teams within banks and
other security companies
study these banking Trojans
all the time with VT in order
to understand, for instance,
where is the stolen data being
sent to--
which is the command and
control for the malware--
so that they can take
down that command control.
And all of a sudden, they
might fix tons of infections
worldwide just by
taking down the network
infrastructure of the Trojan.
MARK MANDEL: There's
something I also
want to highlight, I
think, that's actually
super interesting.
You also run
basically what looks
like a research community--
like, the VirusTotal community?
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: Yeah, so it's over
600,000 researchers that sign
up into VirusTotal.
There's several reasons
why they sign up.
One of them is because they want
to vote on the files and URLs
that they scan with VT in
order to, for instance,
highlight malicious stuff that's
undetected by the anti-virus
and security industry today.
So that way they can
share this information
with the actual
malware researchers
doing the detections.
Another reason for
signing up is that they
get to get an API key to
do some programmatic work
with the VirusTotal data set.
And not only can they vote
on items, like I said,
they can also place
comments, giving you
the entire background on a
given file that they uploaded.
So for instance, on a given
file that they upload,
they might place a comment
that has the actual spam
email from which the file came.
And then there's this really
nice contextual information
for the anti-virus
and security industry,
because not only they
get to see the bullet,
but they also get to
see what the gun was.
And perhaps, even,
they get to understand
who the guy with the gun was.
So for many, the end goal is
to actually understand and know
your enemy.
So the bullet is not enough.
You have to see
the entire picture.
And actually the community
helps in that sense.
MELANIE WARRICK: Where are areas
that you'd like the community
to provide more help or more
support or more insights?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: Right now, we are
actually doing a nice effort.
And we have today the
[INAUDIBLE] of our AV partners.
And we recently
launched an initiative,
which we call The
Multisandbox Project.
So I mentioned that we have
our own virtual set-up where
we run samples.
Right now, we are
collaborating also
with some partners
and new companies that
want to give us sandboxing
execution behavior
data for the samples that
we have and that they see,
so that not only
we have the notion
of what a file
does upon execution
from the VT point of view but
also from other points of view.
And this is really important,
because often malware does
some kind of cloaking,
whereby perhaps it
won't execute in Spain, whereas
it will execute in China.
And so if we have partners
all over the world,
we get to see
different behaviors.
And we get stealthier
against malware
that's trying to evade
this Sandbox system.
So that's something that
I would like to actually
have more partners working on.
Right now, we have like, I
think, four different companies
providing Sandbox reports.
And we are quickly growing this.
But I would like more
information in that sense.
MELANIE WARRICK: How
do they get involved?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: It actually
started off at something called
the Anti-Malware Testing
Standards Organization in 2017
or 2018, I think.
So one of the AV
partners approached us
and said, "Hey, we not only
want to be an AV verdicts
kind of partner of VT.
We would like to also
provide our Sandbox reports.
Why?
Because our
off-the-shelf solution
not only does like
static detection
but also does
behavioral detection.
And we want users to know that
we have different layers built
into our solution.
And if, like, a malware
evades the static detection
layer it might get caught
by a subsequent layer--
for instance, the
behavior detection one.
So they approached us
and suggested this.
It made a lot of sense for us.
So we got them on board.
And when we did
that, we launched
this initiative called
the Multisandbox Project
in our blog.
We reached out to our
partners to tell them
that we were starting this.
And thereafter,
VirusTotal is very--
even if it's not known
by my mom at home--
it's very known in
the security industry.
So it's just people e-mailing
us and saying, "Hey, we
do have a Sandbox set-up.
Can we join?"
MARK MANDEL: So I
double-checked our website.
Apparently, we're clean.
I checked ukgcppodcast.com.
I just wanted to make sure.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's good to know.
MARK MANDEL: It's goo to know.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
I'm sure it's also now
just made people go,
"Hmm, I wonder if I
should try to attack that."
[VIDEO GAME SOUND]
MARK MANDEL: Please don't.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are you hiring?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: So,
yes, we are hiring.
So if you know the
story behind us,
OK, we were an
independent company.
We were acquired
by Google in 2012.
We were integrated in
the Google Security Team.
At one point, it made sense
for us to do something bigger.
So we went on to
Google X. In Google X,
there's been a much bigger
effort around security, which
now has graduated from Google
X into an independent alphabet
company called Chronicle.
And Chronicle, as a whole, is.
Hiring Chronicle should
be the alphabet company
that will address and do the
big moonshots in the security
landscape.
So it's really the
place you want to be at.
And we are hiring both at
VirusTotal in Malaga, Spain
but, most importantly, here
in the US in Chronicle.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Before we wrap up
today, is there
anything else you want
to plug, any events
you're going to
be at, or anything
we haven't managed to cover
in the podcast to make
sure we get everything in?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: We
do, every so often,
this Data Connectors events.
We are going to be in
San Jose on July 12th,
in Raleigh on July 26th,
and BSides, Las Vegas.
And that's an important one,
because Black Hat, which
is the biggest hacker conference
is happening at that time,
will be in August.
So basically, if you want
to reach out and meet us,
just come by and perhaps
send out an email
to info@virustotal.com.
And we will be very happy
to meet you at Black Hat.
MARK MANDEL: So, Emi, is there
anything else inside Google
Cloud that you use?
I mean, you mentioned
App Engine and GCE,
but you've got lots of data.
What do you do in there?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: We are probably
the guys that use most GCP
technologies from the user base.
I won't bet on that.
But, for sure, we use a
wide variety of tools.
So for instance,
I mentioned that
every single compressed file
that gets uploaded to VT we
decompress, and we upload
the inner contents to VT
to see if there is
anything malicious there
and build the
parent-child relationship.
We do that with
Kubernetes engine
as a microservice that
subscribes to that pubsub topic
that we mentioned before.
So many of the
microservices that we run
are actually containers
in Google Cloud.
Something else we
can do, for instance,
is we are really heavy
users of BigQuery.
We do it for two things--
in order to do
analytics over our data
set, and we plug it into stuff
like Google Cloud Data Studio
in order to do nice
charts and graphs
and understand how our users
are using the platform.
But also, we even use it for
advanced and malware research
in use cases.
So for instance,
BigQuery has this thing
which allows you to insert
user-defined functions, which
you write JavaScript,
and it gets
executed against every single
row that you have in BigQuery.
So in the malware field,
there's this thing
called ssdeep, which is
like a fuzzy hash that
allows you to understand
similarity between files.
So there's no way you can
search for similar files
over a two-billion collection
with standard tools.
Why?
Because it means that
you have to compare
this hash and the computation
against every other item
in the data set.
So that's two
billion comparisons,
and you want quick results.
So we plug this into BigQuey.
And within seconds,
we know what are
the files similar to a given
sample that interests you.
And this is done,
because we have
edit distance running as
user-defined functions
in BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
EMI MARTÍNEZ: For instance,
since we are users
of the standard App Engine
environment but also
of the Flex environment,
whenever we would have to run,
for instance, like stuff that
won't be only Python only
or Golang only.
So we have containers deployed
in Google App and in Flex.
And Flex and happens to not
have the standard environment
memcache.
So we are also users
of Memory Store,
which is a recent thing
that was announced.
And we are using memcache
with Memory Store in App
and in Flex.
We are also users, for
instance, of Google Cloud SQL.
Our main data set is actually
in the Cloud data store.
But we have minor App
Engine services, which run,
for instance, WordPress
for our learning space,
which is VirusTotal.com/Learn.
So that's our WordPress
running in Google App Engine
standard environment
in the PHP environment.
And that connects an
SQL, which happens
to be a Google Cloud SQL.
As I said, we're also using
App Engine Flex, not only in
the standard environment.
We do so when we
have a need to run
a certain code that's not only
a Python only or Golang only.
And since App
Engine Flex is a bit
different to the
standard environment,
it doesn't have
the memcached API.
So we needed something
like memcache.
So what we are using instead of
that is the Cloud Memorystore
offering that
recently got launched,
which is built with Redis.
And that's been really useful,
because before that, either
we had to call out some
kind of internal API
that was built in the App
Engine standard environment.
Now we no longer
have to do that.
We are also power users of
stuff like the IM administration
for our users.
So we need to make sure that,
for instance, an intern doesn't
get to deploy code through our
main production site and stuff.
So we manage that with
groups within the G
Suite, because VirusTotal
[INAUDIBLE] happens to be also
a G Suite account.
So we have groups set up there.
And then those groups
have certain privileges
in Google Cloud Dashboard.
So that's the way that
we manage our users
and make sure that no one should
be doing what they are not
allowed to do.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a lot of stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
It's like everything,
all the things.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, and
the one fun question
I want to ask as well-- what
languages do you write in?
EMI MARTÍNEZ: Yeah, so most
of our code is in Python.
We love Python, and it's
very typical in the security
industry.
But we also have some App
Engine services running
with Go in the Go environment.
Since we have WordPress set up
for our very small use case,
that's on the PHP runtime.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Emi, thank you so much
for hanging out with us today.
It was super interesting
to hear about VirusTotal
and what you're all doing
in the security space.
EMI MARTÍNEZ: Thank
you very much.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: So I want to
say thanks to Emi Martínez
for joining us today
from VirusTotal.
That was a super
interesting conversation.
Security research is
really fascinating.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely
agree with you on that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Very important topic.
OK, well, Mark,
question of the week.
MARK MANDEL:
Question of the week.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This week's question
is coming from one
of our listeners.
MARK MANDEL: It is.
It's coming from Andy
Sheridan @AndyJSH.
He asks what is the best
practice for multi-tenancy
in Google Cloud
Spanner, especially
if customers are
not the same size
and potentially
have unequal load?
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
And so for this week's
answer, we actually
have one of our
colleagues, Robert Kubis,
who is joining us to
basically answer the question.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
for joining us,
Robert, because I have no idea.
How are you doing today, Robert?
ROBERT KUBIS: Very good.
Thank you for having me.
And hello, everyone.
So this is actually a
really, really good question.
And to basically
elaborate a little bit
on how a spanner works behind
the scenes-- so in Spanner,
our data is organized
based on the primary key.
So the primary key
you choose, that's
how we order the
data in Spanner.
And then we split these
data up in chunks.
And these chunks'
responsibilities
goes to the Spanner nodes that
you have in your instance.
So now, that means,
basically, if you
have like multi-tenant
application
and you use a custom ID, as
an example, for a primary key,
then all your data which is
belonging to one customer
would go to one node.
And basically this one node
is responsible for that.
And that can lead to
things like hot spotting.
So all your load-- which is
all the data that is loaded,
all the data that is
read, all the queries that
are going against
this customer--
basically have to be
handled by one node.
Now, you don't want
that, especially
in cases where
you have customers
which are of unequal size.
So you have some large customers
and a lot of small ones.
And a good way to addressing
this is somehow you
have to basically
split up your data
in a way that the
responsibility can
be given to multiple
nodes in your instance.
One of the best practices that
a lot of people are doing there
is basically prefixing
your primary key
or using a larger primary
key in your tables.
So a prefix could
be, for example, you
could use some other
element in your table.
And you hash that
element, and you take
that as a prefix in your key.
And with that, your
data is basically
distributed among
multiple nodes.
And now, if you have
very large customers,
it gets distributed between
the available resources,
and it doesn't
matter if you have
a couple of large customers
and a couple of small ones.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is great.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Robert, thank you
so much for joining us today
to help answer that question.
And if anybody else out there
has more questions, please
feel free to message us.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Actually, sir, usually
when we leave off,
we talk about where
we're going to be.
Robert, are you doing
any events soon?
Are you talking about
Spanner anywhere
if anyone wants to learn
more about Spanner,
since we have you here?
ROBERT KUBIS: Yeah, sure.
So the next big event
that is coming up for us
is, of course, NEXT
in San Francisco.
I think, by now, everybody
is speaking about it.
I will be there.
I have two sessions.
And one is actually
on Advanced Topics
in Cloud Spanner--
like how to design
your schemes to really get
the best out of Cloud Spanner.
So I'm going to talk about this.
I'm going to talk about
metrics, about how
to tune Cloud Spanner basically
to the best of your needs.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark,
where are you going to be?
MARK MANDEL: So, yeah.
I'm just like Robert.
I'm going to be at NEXT.
I'm going be speaking
about Agones.
It's the Open Source
project I've been working on
for running game servers.
I think I may be doing
some other stuff.
But yeah, you and I are
going to be there, Melanie,
doing some podcasting stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, we will.
MARK MANDEL: And Melanie,
where are you going to be?
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm going
to be speaking, actually,
in the next couple of
weeks at PyCon, Russia.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I will be speaking
about reinforcement
learning on the 22nd of July.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
then I'll be NEXT--
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--as will we all.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie,
Robert, thank you very
much for joining us in another
weekly episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
ROBERT KUBIS: Thank
you for having me.
MARK MANDEL: All right, and
thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]